hello and welcome to the new world
review a source for everything anime and
manga mostly hunter hunter i will admit
and on that note more specifically
welcome to the
encyclopedia a clever play on words
there where we will be specifically
diving into and detailing the wide range
of abilities demonstrated in hunter
hunter commencing here today with our
classic protagonist lad boy
gone freaks and if you're thinking that
gone is an overly simplistic individual
whose abilities really don't need a
whole video of their own well i don't
think you're quite giving mr gone enough
credit here it's
actually pretty amazing what this little
guy can do with very simple concepts
like rock paper scissors in fact
let's play right now just to give us a
taste so what i'm going to do is i'm
going to count down from three at which
point i want you to select rock paper or
scissors to face me in battle and if you
lose then you need to subscribe to the
new world review which will grant you
regular hunt onto content uploaded
straight into your youtube feed so the
whole concept of losing is quite
arguable really
but all right now that we've got the
rules are you ready let's go three
two one go that's right i chose
trusty old rock so for anyone who went
scissors please do press that delightful
red button and i welcome you
into our association in any case that
was the power of rock paper scissors
without men because i am not fortunate
enough to be an end user myself but gone
takes all of this to the extreme
starting with some basic information
though this is something that can often
be forgotten about gone but he has an
extraordinary natural talent for aura
manipulation
in fact it has been stated that both he
and kilauea possess a raw affinity for
nen that can only be found in roughly 1
out of every 10
million people 10 million being quite a
lot and i don't think that that truly
comes across in hunter hunter because we
only really follow gone through his
discovery of nine we never get to see
him land at a level of mastery which all
of his major opponents tend to have
attained so yes gone looks significantly
underpowered compared to experienced
users like his various teachers wing
bisky and kite
as well as established antagonists like
kuvagine hisoka and you know what even
genthrough all of these figures tend to
dwarf gone but at the same time you do
need to remember that this sort of
comparison is similar to the idea of a
30 year old man challenging a toddler to
a game of chess
it doesn't matter how much natural
talent the toddler has they will
inevitably lose to the experience and
developmental advantages of the 30 year
old adult
so that is gone struggle he possesses
the ultimate talent but almost none of
the required experience
and with that in mind he does pretty
damn well just to compete in this series
and just to really emphasize how absurd
gone's abilities are he was able to
learn both ren and gyo in a single
evening each
meanwhile we have a direct comparison in
zushi who took two whole weeks to
accomplish even a single aspect of
producing iren and zushi himself is also
quite a unique talent when it comes to
nen a rising star of the art form by
any metric however gone quite frankly
makes zushi look like a struggling
student so with that in mind let's step
beyond the basic and even intermediate
applications of nen because it'll be the
same story if it's a universal use of
aura gone will master it in no time at
all but that brings us to the crowning
feature of the art form which is how
gone makes individual and unique use of
his order and in terms of this gone is a
natural enhancer which is known as the
most balanced in affinity it allows for
both great offense and
fantastic defense with the primary
application of aura being used to
increase
gun's physical abilities as well as
condense his aura into some pretty
wildly powerful attacks
before we get to that though one heavily
underrated feature of gon's enhancement
prowess is how ridiculously durable he
becomes with nenus
in the series gone has tanked several
attacks that should have utterly
destroyed him and likely would have
taken out non-enhancers on collision
such as characters of even kilowatt
caliber who was a transmuter but for
example let's take
baro the uh the armadillo camaro ant
thing
usually pretty irrelevant in any
discussion however he managed to catch
gone completely off guard with one of
his attacks
and whilst barra himself was not an end
user he did state that after being hit
every other human
quite literally puked their guts out
which is
a lovely image and assumedly they would
have died shortly after given that their
insides would have now been their
outsides meanwhile gone with the most
basic and improvised defense he could
muster took no real damage which really
does show off his talent for enhancement
for a nen related example though on
greed island gone was able to block one
of razer's nen
infused throws during the dodgeball
match which is no easy feat considering
he is a natural emitter
although this was not his most powerful
attack that would have been the
volleyball spike which gone did block
although he required the assistance of
both kilauea and hisoka to do so but
when it comes to attacking gon is able
to transfer 100
of this defensive ability into an
equitably devastating output as is the
great advantage of balance granted by
enhancement
all of which manifests itself through
the jejuncan set of techniques and the
name itself is a play on the word junkin
which is the japanese equivalent of rock
paper scissors and rather predictably
gone has three options available to him
which are named after
rock paper and scissors respectively so
starting with rock this attack is by far
gone's most powerful
as it takes advantage of raw enhancement
and in terms of how it looks we
basically see gon build up an
exceptional amount of aura and use it to
punch an enemy its outward simplicity is
quite deceptive though because in order
to perform this very straightforward
attack gone needs to combine
several other uses of nine the basis of
the entire attack being co
an advanced application of nen taut gone
by biscuit the result of which is a
complete concentration of aura around a
particular body part which will
generally be a fist for gone however
this technique is also
horrifically complex to master because
it involves a combination of every basic
principle being 10
ren zetsu and hatsu in addition to
adding gyo on top so that is five
simultaneous areas to balance
just to achieve a solid co and this is
then taken a huge sleep further with
rock because rather than building up a
stable co gon instead chooses to focus
all of his aura into it and when you
have rather exceptional
natural reserves of aura this becomes
quite a terrifying prospect
furthermore the resulting rock would be
all the more powerful should gon have
enough time to build up his rent to a
critical mass
unfortunately time is one of the many
problems with rock though
as an inexperienced nen user it takes
gone an awfully long time to concentrate
the entirety of his aura into
a single position thus giving a
competent opponent plenty of time to
counter the obviously flagged incoming
attack
also due to using the entirety of aura
within rock gone loses any defensive
capabilities he has as an enhancer
meaning that more often than not rock is
an all or nothing technique that when
used needs to end the battle right then
and there otherwise well
we have problems but recognizing the
need for versatility gone would also
delve into his neighboring net
affinities which would firstly present
itself
in the scissors attack rather than being
enhancement gone now wields
transmutation
giving his built up horror the qualities
of a blade like object and the
advantages of scissors are twofold
firstly as opposed to rock scissors is a
more mid-ranged attack and very much
works as if gone is wielding an actual
weapon so it increases his range which
is very helpful given that he
is a small child thing and landing hits
with his teeny tiny arms can be tricky
at times secondly whilst the aura output
is weaker than that of rock due to gun
obviously not being a natural transmuter
scissors is actually a much more precise
move capable of comfortably slicing
through certain defenses that even the
blunt force of rock would not be able to
penetrate
giving gone a very nice option against
particularly durable opponents and
finally we also have paper which sees
gon invoke his other neighboring
affinity
being emission so same basic principle
gone charges up his aura but this time
the plan is to fire it
in something akin to a classical ki
blast the idea of which is to give gon a
long-range attack for certain situations
although this does come at a great cost
to general power the problem being that
emission is one slot removed on the
n-ring and in addition to that using
emission also naturally reduces oral
potency even in natural emitters
actually although they have more options
available to mitigate that loss
so paper despite having the same aura
cost as rock is only about one quarter
of the power having been halved once by
delving into a mission and halved again
by the unfortunate base cost of a
mission so if anything paper is an even
more situational technique than scissors
forcing gone to think very strategically
in theory anyway and what i also haven't
mentioned thus far is that these attacks
all begin with gun performing a trusty
little chant
which goes as follows first comes rock
rock paper
and then whatever the name of the attack
is and this might seem a bit arbitrary i
mean it is a common shonen trope to
announce attacks for the benefit of the
readers or watchers
but in this case it is also entirely
possible that gone has put a nen
limitation on himself
increasing the general capabilities of
the moveset but under the condition that
he needs to perform the ritualistic
chant which isn't to say that gon has
necessarily done that
consciously either it may very well be
an unconscious limitation but it is
there in all but one specific case
and that would be the evolution of
jejunkin which occurred during the
chimera ant arc where gon developed
round two and in theory this allows gone
to use two dejunking techniques in quick
succession with the second one not
requiring the chat but instead the
simple
declaration of round two which in theory
gives gon infinitely more versatility
able to now mix and match to drunken
abilities although we never really got
to see
the great effect of that but these three
attacks form gon's base moveset and they
do tend to work quite well for him gone
as with most shonen protagonists does
have a keen sense for battle but even
then he is far from a genius in combat
so restricting himself to this
simplistic set of moves that provide him
with versatility without need to engage
in too much thinking
is quite perfect for the gone that we
know and assumedly he would have
continued to grow those subtleties and
complexities over the course of his
development
or he would have anyway if you know the
uh the thing didn't happen
that thing being gone's most powerful
invocation of nen which is quite
possibly the most single powerful use of
men that we have ever seen in the series
arguably anyway but during the late
stages of the chimera and talk gone was
thrust into the depths of despair making
a bit of a rash decision to say the
least
but this moment is why i went to great
lengths to detail gone's natural talent
throughout the video because what we are
now about to see
would have been the culmination of all
of that talent in gonzald form this
transformation was achieved by gone
performing a nen val to summon up all of
the power he would ever have
and in exchange for this brief period
gone was willing to throw away all of
his talent and become
unable to use nen ever again as well as
throw away his life into a form that
ilmizoldic described as a fate worse
than death
but what's most unclear about this usage
is what brand of nan gone used to make
this a reality
kind of like biski's transformation it
doesn't cleanly fall into the
established affinities and there is
every chance that gon evolved into a
specialist
just to perform this that or it is the
most extreme
incarnation of enhancement possible to
enhance your body to a time of growth
and power
necessary to overcome a certain enemy
but in this form gone
completely eclipsed the royal guard
nephipito in every conceivable area
in fact call their following encounter a
fight would be incorrect
it was a murder with gone taking brutal
retribution for what had happened to
kite and as for just how powerful gone
became
well it's pretty difficult to quantify
many fans including myself have often
stated allogant being equal to that of
meruem but that may not be true in
actuality the statement pito made
regarding this
was that his fangs may even be able to
sink into the king which is nice and
poetic but it still shows a much higher
regard for meruem although gone did
become a significant threat whatever the
case we do know that adult gone is one
of the most powerful existences in olive
hunt hunter but once again that came at
a huge cost
gone was willing to sacrifice literally
everything his nan
his life and even his status as a
protagonist in the series
because whilst gone was saved by killua
and alaka to this day he remains unable
to use nen
and has thus retired to whale island to
live life as a normal child for a bit of
a change that isn't to say that he
doesn't have the potential to reawaken
it but given the strength of the vow he
made it would be supremely unlikely
and there we have the surprisingly
tragic tale of gons and inabilities
a character with supreme natural talent
although we as readers and watchers
only got to see a brief glimpse of that
true potential but hey that's just the
nature of hunthunter and a big part of
why i love it but what do you guys think
please do leave your thoughts in the
comments below or even join my discord
server and if you're keen for some more
hunt hunter content then please do go
and check out some of my other videos or
even subscribe to the channel for
regular hunt on
glory delivered straight into your
youtube feed but for now this has been
the new world review and i'll see you
next time